Daniel Magyar the sponsor of this next
segment is a personal trainer in weight
loss expert his new book weight loss
without Plateau is now a best-selling
book on three sectors of Amazon and he
joins us now congratulations on the book
Thank you very much I really appreciate
it best-selling book that's fantastic
what is inside this book what are we
going to find inside this book so during
the last 11 years in coaching people
and weight loss I've seen many people
plateau and there's nothing more
frustrating than working hard and
dieting hard and I didn't results for it
so um it is important to understand that
Plateau is a natural process and body
actually wants to do it
so in this book I explain exactly the
reason why the body wants the plateau
and how to prevent it step-by-step guide
how to prevent the plateau a lot of it
is understanding human body's metabolism
and its ability to adapt to a low
calorie intake for a long period of time
so basically if you're in a calorie
deficit for a long period of time
there's something to the chairs it's
called metabolic adaptation
so the bottom line is someone's losing
some weight all of a sudden it just
stops and you're trying everything
trying everything this is the secret to
punching through exactly step-by-step
guide you look at you you're in great
physical shape I asked Daniel before we
started saying like what gym do you work
out you don't go to the gym where do you
work out not at home with resistance
bands I call the system called uh I
sorry I use the system called that's
three and it takes me about 20 to 25
minutes to exercise and that's it that's
all my resistance training for today
because you're an amazing shape what
services do you offer to people watching
right now you have weight loss personal
training so it is online coaching most
of my programs are online and I coach
people from point A to point B anywhere
from weight loss to muscle building to
sometimes bodybuilding competitions I
was looking at your Instagram too it's
full of tips and everything what is your
Instagram handle someone's watching
right now they want to get your website
they want to follow you on Instagram
because you are a great follower when it
comes to health tips and workout tips
what's the Instagram handle VM
underscore trainer someone's watching
right now going into the weekend what's
what's one tip you can give them when it
comes to weight loss or maybe someone
wants to put on some muscle what's that
one little tip that you can give them
going into the weekend try the sugar
alcohol and fried food one more time cut
sugar alcohol sugar alcohol fried foods
that's the secret right there cut it out
and so no no cocktails tonight after
work is what you're telling me so if
you're trying to beat your healthiest
and then just move too right get up to
physical activity a lot of physical
activity resistant training will be
number one in high intensity interval
training of course the hit cardio I
would definitely interpret that in a
lifestyle and Daniel real quick the book
to weight loss without Plateau we can
get this on Amazon absolutely and if
you're if you have some kind of weight
loss routine diet and exercising it's
not working this is the secret to punch
through and get those extra results 100
beautiful Daniel thank you so much for
joining us Las Vegas now we'll be right
back